what happens is you you know continue to
scale and continue to make more money
continue to have stuff that works is
that
the better you are the better the
opportunities that you have to say no to
[Music]
are
i wanted to make a another little video
for you because it was on my mind and i
thought it was uh
i was telling someone else about the
story and i figured i might as well
share with you guys
so um so some of you guys might know uh
we were just at the uh funnel hacking
live event where some of the speakers
were talking about high ticket sales
and um you know we won in the one of the
rewards which is like it's called the
axe award
which is um it means you did over 10
million in sales
which is pretty cool um i mean we were
excited about it but
i mean it's awesome but the the thing
that happened afterwards
is where i kind of want to bring the
lesson home so i had a couple people
after we you know spoke and
um we were kind of showcased as kind of
a success story type thing
um who were like hey you know could you
consult for my business i'd like to do
something like this in my space and
chiropractors and dentists or blah blah
blah right
and people um offered to pay us
50 000 for a single day we had two
people come up and offer that
um for us to kind of coach them on their
business help them scale help them
start doing high ticket whatever right
and
my wife uh before i even had a chance to
answer the question
um step forward and said no we don't do
that
and um i wanted to kind of highlight why
it was important and why
um why that kind of attitude has
helped us grow so fast and so what
happens is you
you know continue to scale and continue
to make more money and continue to have
stuff that works is that
the better you are better the
opportunities that you have to say no to
are and so what happens especially as
entrepreneurs a lot of times we see
things that we're like
man this would be so cool i got like six
businesses and like none of them really
make money but like
like i don't know which one i'm gonna do
but i'm gonna invest in all of them and
like i'm gonna see which one takes off
but like that's fundamentally flawed
because you as an entrepreneur make any
business take off and any single
business can be as big as you want it to
be
and so all you're doing when you're
diluting your attention is you're
diluting your attention and then
ultimately you're
ensuring that none of them will work
right and so
we turn down these 250 000 a day
consulting clients because
the attention that that would take is
going to take more from our business
than it will give us
um and making decisions in that way has
been
probably the number one thing that has
grown us to where we are now i can't
tell you the amount of guys who i think
are um
than we are and it's because they can't
focus
like they cannot focus they can't stick
to one thing they do launch after launch
they switch product they switch
industries they switch customer avatars
they're like well i was thinking about
doing this and i was doing this
and um they just can't stick with it
right and if you look at our business
right and if you look at our gym model
and then if you look at our current
gym launch business it's all about doing
the same thing over and over and over
again and it's so boring
it's so boring right all you do is you
get really good at doing one thing and
then
that's it and as much as you want to do
the next thing all you do is you go back
to that first thing and you do it better
and you do it better and you do it
better right and that's all you do is
you continue to scale if you look at the
difference between a 30 million
your business and 100 million your
business so right now we're on pace for
a 30 million dollar
uh run rate is where we're at now um if
you look at that
versus 100 million business they're
virtually the same
the only thing that changes is that 100
million business does more
of the same thing they just do more
instead of having ten set up five sales
a day they do 15 sales a day
that's it it's the only difference
they're not doing new verticals they're
not
constantly um trying to sell different
things
they usually cut focus on the same
customer avatar and they solve the same
problem that they're really good at
solving they sell it better
and that's it and so by us turning down
these 250 000
a day consulting deals i can guarantee
you that having that fitness
is what has been some of the reasons for
our successes that we've been able to
focus on doing one
for you to not look at if you're a gym
owner
not look at online training not look at
meal prep services not look at
um all the many things that you can do
that will distract you
um you know doing this jv or doing this
this
50 50 thing with my buddy who's got this
little thing going on the side like
there are always things but i can
guarantee you that they always have
strings attached
and the strings are attached to your
attention and that's the most valuable
asset you have now your time it's your
attention
and so even if we did do this 50 000
consulting day even if we did do this 50
000 consulting day
um what would end up happening is
that person after that dance would still
try and take attention and ultimately
what that will do
not allow us to fulfill on the promise
that we made to our initial gym owners
who came
to us and so if i take that same amount
of attention
and then i put it towards the existing
model we have and brick by brick
continue to stack
you'll make more and more and more
focusing on those fundamentals
than you want anything else so um
sometimes you got to do more to do less
and i had a mentor once
sometimes you got to go slow to go fast
and i really believe in that
and he was the ceo of a 10 billion
dollar company with a b
10 billion and um i had an extended
period of time where i was
working really really closely with him
and i learned a lot of things from him
and um
that was one of them was that sometimes
you have to go slow to go fast
and sometimes you just gotta get good at
one thing and all you have to do is
focusing on doing that thing more and
more despite being an entrepreneur and
wanting to do lots of things
the ones who make the most money are the
ones who do the least right
and by at least i'm not saying you don't
work i'm saying you do the least amount
of things and you just do a few things
extremely well
so double down on that don't get
distracted with shiny objects
the better you are the better the
opportunities you have to say no to
so keep that in the back your mind say
no to the meal prep service say no to
the online training thing say hello to
the training from afar say no to the
the you know the little corporate deal
that you might be able to set up
um because they will distract you from
the main thing because those are not the
end goal
and if you have the gym selling them
giving amazing results get them to send
more people to you
and do that over and over and over and
over again and then one day you will
look up and you'll be really really
that's the point all right it's awesome
a lot of us are just used to struggle
and we basically self sabotage
um by just putting some more stuff on a
stuff on our plate rather than just
focusing some of you guys right now have
multiple things on your plate and you
can't focus on it
um but imagine if you only had one thing
to focus on
maybe it was one location you have three
and you know you should have done it you
should have only had one
how easy would it be to make money with
one location super easy because you have
all your attention on it
right but some of you are making
attention with three right maybe not
making money with three
same thing if you're multiple businesses
you can't make it right a lot of times
because your attention is still split so
focus in on one thing that makes you
money
and do that over and over and over and
over again until you're sick of it
and then do more of it and i promise
you'll make money all right lots of love
guys hope you have an amazing day
and i'll catch you guys
[Music]
you